bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 en donde analizamos la
actualidad de la eurocopa y la copa
américa a continuación los titulares
alegría en budapest las selecciones de
hungría y francia empataron a un gol
el resultado fue celebrado como un
triunfo para los húngaros que se
mantienen con vida en el torneo tenemos
reportes de este país
clásico o sin goles al igual que en 1872
fecha del primer enfrentamiento entre
las selecciones de inglaterra y escocia
esta vez empataron sin goles en su duelo
por la presente edición de la eurocopa
hay preocupación en el conjunto de
gareth southgate en breve el análisis
argentina se queda con el clásico del
río de la plata' los dirigidos por
lionel scaloni ganaron en la segunda
fecha del grupo a y junto al chile
tomaron posición de lo más alto de la
tabla
uruguay quede en deuda pero ya piensa en
su próximo partido frente a los chilenos
tenemos análisis y reacciones
gracias por estar con nosotros y vamos a
empezar hablando el día de hoy de la
selección francesa y para ello en breve
vamos a establecer contacto con nuestra
compañera en la redacción de france 24
en parís
natalia ruiz giraldo también hoy
contamos con el placer de la compañía de
sara castro directora del diario 'as'
colombia bienvenida sahara hola luis un
gusto acompañarlos mucho fútbol y muchas
cosas por analizar por supuesto que sí
una jornada que comenzó muy muy temprano
y el primer partido de la misma tuvo
presente a la selección francesa que
rescató un punto en lo que fue su
segundo partido frente a la
representación de hungría en estos
momentos se desarrolla el segundo
partido del día y del grupo
efe entre portugal y alemania más
adelante cerrará la jornada con ese
partido entre polonia y españa pero
antes de entrar en materia vamos a
escuchar el reporte de nuestra compañera
natalia ruiz sobre lo que fueron las
impresiones del partido entre fran
y hungría una sorpresa húngara se llevó
la selección francesa en el buscas arena
en budapest en este su segundo partido
de la eurocopa francia tuvo muchos
inconvenientes para tomar el ritmo que
le impuso hungría durante el primer
tiempo sin embargo logró hacerse con la
posesión de la pelota y tener ocasiones
muy claras de gol sin embargo bastó un
error de la zaga francesa en el minuto
47 ya en tiempo adicional y fue a tila
fiola el encargado de marcar para
hungría convertirse en el héroe nacional
de esas 60.000 almas que estaban hoy en
este estadio con el ciento por ciento de
aforo en el segundo tiempo francia salió
buscando el empate pero sobre todo la
victoria era lo que necesitaba y bueno
en el minuto 66 llegó el descuento
gracias a junto a nagy rayas man el
francés del barcelona quien marcó un
bellísimo gol gran gesto de francés con
un zurdazo y sin embargo francia no
volvió a llegar al arco húngaro no pudo
convertir a pesar de los diferentes
cambios que hizo de su y bueno pues
francia pone un poquito en dificultad su
pase a la siguiente ronda
definitivamente un partido muy
complicado para la selección francesa
que debió remar contracorriente a pesar
de crear y crear oportunidades de gol
frente a esta representación de hungría
que se puede esperar de francia para lo
que queda de esta primera fase del
torneo
natalia hacia un resumen muy interesante
de lo que fue el partido y yo creo que
lo que vamos a hacer es empezar a
sumarle adjetivos de esta hungría ya
habíamos hablado de su intensidad hoy
vamos a hablar de su combatividad yo
creo que el equipo de champs estuvo bien
planteado intentó avasallar a ese bloque
defensivo que logró montar hungría pero
se le complicó luego la entrada dembélé
fue muy importante para agitar esa banda
liberar a griezmann y lograr ese empate
no le alcanzó el tiempo
a francia pero creo que es un grupo muy
cerrado ellos tienen jugadores muy
interesantes y por supuesto no se van a
encontrar siempre con estos bloques
defensivos como tan férreos un poco más
de espacio creo que esto también los
pone en ritmo de competencia y luego
clasificar a la siguiente ronda aún es
posible es un grupo que tiene equipos
muy importantes y por eso siempre ha
sido denominado
un grupo que está sumamente difícil a la
espera lo que va a hacer es el resultado
entre portugal y alemania pero hablando
más de esta eurocopa de naciones ayer
hubo acción en los grupos de pie por el
grupo e suecia venció a eslovaquia un
gol por 0 mientras que hubo una jornada
de empates en el grupo de 1 a 1
croacia y la república checa- y sin
goles cerró el clásico entre inglaterra
y escocia uno de los partidos más
longevos en cuanto al fútbol sara
retomando el tema de este último partido
en el caso de inglaterra escocia debe
preocuparse soft kate por la situación
del conjunto no se están viendo los
goles que esperaba el equipo inglés en
este torneo hay bastantes críticas sobre
el manejo que está haciendo saudí a la
cantidad de talentos que tienen cuando
uno revisa la nómina de inglaterra
estamos hablando de una de las mejores
generaciones básica de la historia y no
logró descifrar el partido los cambios
no funcionaron intentó sacando a fonden
que siempre resulta
la llave para inglaterra entonces se le
está cuestionando mucho eso la gestión
de los talentos por supuesto para
escocia fue un empate más que valioso ya
lo mencionaban ustedes 1872 estamos
hablando de historia del fútbol cuando
se enfrentan en la inglaterra y escocia
lo de wembley sigue siendo emocionante
22.500 personas en las tribunas y ahí es
donde hasta ahora la uefa dijo que se
disputará la final por supuesto que sí
pero también hay que hablar de otro
equipo que está siendo muy seguido en
esta eurocopa y es el caso de república
checa más allá de no contar con esas
figuras de la década de mediados de los
90 que revolucionaron incluso fueron
subcampeones de una eurocopa podemos
estar hablando de una generación dorada
o el comienzo de una generación dorada
en este conjunto checo república checa-
conoce muy bien lo que hace y también lo
que le falta es decir potencia mucho sus
virtudes e intenta y apalancar como esos
vacíos que tiene dentro del juego luego
se enfrenta a una croacia que no termina
siendo el mismo equipo colectivo y tan
potente del mundial de rusia 2018
tiene también muchos talentos pero si
termina dándoles el empate pero creo que
estamos viendo en general y a pesar de
los empates una propuesta interesante y
como dices aparecen nuevas generaciones
que van poniendo en funcionamiento y
sobre todo creando nuevas rivalidades en
el fútbol europeo el momento de hablar
de la copa américa ayer hubo acción en
donde la selección de chile venció con
marcador de un gol por cero a la
representación de bolivia lo propio hizo
argentina al vencer a uruguay con el
mismo marcador
sara como podemos calificar el partido
de argentina para algunos fue aburrido
para otro fue cerrado como podríamos
buscar un punto medio para mí fue un muy
buen partido de argentina porque en la
primera parte logró imponer condiciones
encontró soluciones cambió cuatro
jugadores sobre todo en la línea
defensiva el técnico lionel scaloni creo
que fue muy buen partido en el primer
tiempo que podemos ver de diferente que
logró mantener la concentración que
logró mantener la intensidad durante
todo el partido y vimos un mes y que no
sólo tiene talento sino que se esfuerza
y eso habla de la ambición
uno de los mejores jugadores de la
historia para llevar esta argentina
hasta la final por parte de uruguay muy
poca producción ofensiva lleva cuatro
partidos sin anotar gol y seguramente
eso le va a costar mucho al equipo de
tabárez te parece si escuchamos
rápidamente lo que dijeron ambos
técnicos
al concluir este encuentro
cosas chiquitas nos quedamos con dos
empates o tres mejor dicho en los
últimos tres partidos que no merecíamos
y hoy creo que el equipo bueno dio ese
plus para de rabia más que todo para
para que no te conviertan una vez que
vas ganando
y soportar
los ataques de rival e intentar hacer
daño cuando cuando se podía también creo
que hoy estuvimos bien en las dos fases
y eso está bien argentina manejó muy
bien con mucho oficio todo eso y bueno y
no pudimos ahora nuestro campeonato se
va a jugar en estos tres partidos en
donde aspiramos a lograr la
clasificación
por otro lado ya lo adelantamos otro
partido chile venció a la representación
de bolivia una bolivia que dirige césar
farías que se mostró como un duro
oponente sobre todo en la segunda mitad
del partido pero sigue sin conseguir
llevar la pelota a la red por otro lado
chile sigue haciendo lo suyo que podemos
esperar de esta chile que está
dirigiendo martín lasarte chile tiene
jugadores de mucha jerarquía y ya esa
idea de lasarte está empezando a calar y
se ve en el funcionamiento sobre todo en
la primera parte como dices nos quedamos
con el nombre deben ver en tono es este
jugador que llamo reinaldo rueda desde
diciembre del año pasado cuando hacía
parte del cuerpo técnico de chile y lo
sumo es un jugador de madre chilena y
padre británico no habla español pero
marcó este gol de tres puntos que además
lo empieza a poner en la mira del torneo
y los chiles interesantes pero me llama
la atención la valentía de bolivia es un
equipo que no se cansa de buscar durante
todo el partido sin la pelota sufre
mucho lo vimos en la primera parte pero
es un equipo que sigue buscando incluso
sin moreno martins creo que generó
bastantes oportunidades y en él
tiempo alcanzó a poner contra las
cuerdas a chile vamos a escuchar lo que
dijo el técnico chileno precisamente
sobre este partido creo que para venir a
una ocasión importante pero también
difícil jugar como titular en una
selección como tú decías recién donde no
hablan no hablan el idioma aunque él
domina está haciendo un gran esfuerzo
por entender por comprender
los compañeros tienen tienen mucha
responsabilidad sobre esto están
ayudando mucho colaborando mucho y bueno
tuvo su oportunidad y la aprovechó
seguramente para elevación una situación
muy motivante desde el punto de vista de
su ansiedad del debut hacer un gol ver
cómo lo gritó y su gran trabajo este
creo que terminó agotado cosa lógica a
continuación una selección de las
principales noticias que nos deja este
torneo
el inter de milán club donde hace vive
el jugador danés christian eriksen
emitió una carta en donde entre otras
cosas le expresa solidaridad al jugador
que atraviesa por un momento delicado de
salud el club también celebra que ya
esté recuperándose en casa
la uefa debe lo que cuenta con la
capital húngara budapest como plan
alternativo en caso de que londres no
pueda albergar la final de la presente
edición de la eurocopa esta ciudad ha
recibido dos juegos del presente torneo
y ambos se han disputado a plena
capacidad de fanáticos
la conmebol anunció una multa de 20 mil
dólares y un partido de suspensión para
el jugador boliviano marcelo moreno
martins el goleador de la selección del
altiplano se pronunció en redes sociales
en contra del torneo y las autoridades
de la conmebol luego de verse afectados
por el cob y 19
y de esta manera llegamos al final de la
presente emisión del diario de copas
agradeciéndole a sara castro por haber
estado con nosotros un gusto mañana
partidas analizaremos el partidazo entre
alemania y portugal es por supuesto lo
que pasa entre españa y polonia así será
muchísimas gracias
félix tardes para todos
[Música]